what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
man you guys have heard me say it a
million times and you're gonna hear me
say it again old man Logan is probably
the best thing coming out of all-new
all-different waffle right now it's dude
it's nuts how good this story is oh my
god it's so good man like it's COO man
it's it's it's good so um this is
actually a one-shot issue number 8 is a
standalone story there's really nothing
that we need to worry about outside of
this but we do sort of need to know a
little bit of history of old man Logan
the great thing about this is that I've
got videos on it so we don't really have
to do a whole great big recap instead
you'll find those videos down in the
description but the great thing about
this story too though is that even if we
did need to do a recap the story covers
all that force because this talks about
how the supervillains took over the
world in the old man Logan universe oh
man it's not a fool it's not like a
great big huge grandiose play-by-play of
everything that happened but it does
give us a lot more information than we
had before because all we knew from the
old man Logan universe was that
Wolverine had been tricked into killing
all of the all the x-men when the
spider-man villain Mysterio you know
cast a delusion that led him to believe
that all the villains had Justin all the
x-men villains had just shown up at the
x-men mansion but we didn't really know
anything aside from that and so what
this does if this bounce back and forth
between the past the president balances
back and forth between these two places
and what it tells us is that in the old
man Logan universe in the past that the
entire event started when magneto along
with the Green Goblin
along with Polaris when they at all
alongside Hydra just showed up in New
York and man you know literally just
brought down the New York skyline using
his powers of magnetism and and I gotta
tell you guys man that's based god it's
so beast so I've been using its powers
of magnetism just like just rip
everything down to just like bring
everything crumbling down um but the
other thing too though is that this is
hydrant like Hydra is with him now
having said that like mmm we know that
Captain America is a Hydra agent Steve
Rogers is a Hydra agent what if this
happened like what if this actually
happened in the main Marvel Universe god
I'd be so hyped I feel like a kid in a
candy store right now but any of it we
switch over to ex haven now wanting to
keep in mind is
the all-new all-different marvel
universe because of the whole impact
thing because of the Terrigen mist
threatening to wipe out so many x-men in
response the the Xavier Institute was
actually moved to the dimension of limbo
under the control of magic so that way
it actually remains out of the influence
of the Terrigen mist and what this does
it actually allows you know storming the
x-men to run these little campaign
missions where they just basically show
up in earth they grab whatever mutants
they can they just you know take off
back to limbo to the x-men mansion and
because of this you know because of the
events of Berserker because of the
fallout with old man Logan learning
about his history you know the events in
border town and so on and so forth you
know coming to the full realization that
he's not in the old man Logan universe
anymore he had effectively joined the
x-men the kicker to this is that he's
still very uneasy because you know keep
in mind with such a traumatic experience
living through all these things
remembering the events of secret wars in
the mind of old man Logan to quote the
popular phrase from Battlestar Galactica
all of this has happened before and all
of it will happen again and that's his
line of logic his line of logic is when
it comes to these two universes in terms
of how they coexist side by side now is
around the time that the villains took
over the world that they killed off all
the superheroes and so oh man Logan is
getting more and more anxious as the
really as the clock it's to midnight you
know as the Doomsday Clock it gets five
minutes to midnight he's so sure that
these villains are going to show up and
they're going to take everything over
and so because of this you know Jean
Grey of course remember this is Jean
Grey from the past this is the all-new
x-men Jean Grey
she basically picks up on Wolverines
uneasiness and picks up on the idea that
he seems to be experiencing a lot of
anxiety now this is kind of a weird
thing when it comes to the the young
Jean Grey and old man Logan because
Marvel kind of walks this line here in
some stories you know old man Logan's
like a father figure and other stories
the indication is that the two of them
are going to get together which is weird
and that's really really creepy and kind
of gross but the idea here is that even
you know in some form or fashion
regardless of what direction things take
they do have a very very strong
friendship and when old man Logan first
showed up and Jean Grey kind of ran
through his mind on what it is that he
was experiencing she said look if that
happens I will be with you every step of
the way
I will anchor you to reality like I will
be the rock that you can hold on to you
and the waters of reality begin to
become too tumultuous for you to really
navigate you know I will be the one that
will keep you here and keep you sane and
so what we do is we jump back
to Old Men Logan's universe with the
supervillains taking over everything
because I know that's all you guys care
about you don't have to you don't have
to lie I know you guys like we just want
to see how the supervillains took over
the world we don't care about Jean Grey
an old man look but what we do is we
join she-hulk and we join daredevil
along with Moon Knight and Punisher this
is really like a last stand at the
al-imam and you got Captain America
there but it's literally like just a
last stand it's them doing the best they
can and the coolest thing about this is
even though Jeff Lemire doesn't give us
a ton of stuff here you can kind of
imagine battles like this all over the
country all over the world I mean
everywhere you know everywhere because
we know and what Conda this is happening
we know that it's happening in like
England with the with Excalibur I mean
we know it's happening everywhere
probably in the Savage Land although
nobody cares about kazar we know that
all these things are happening all over
the place and with Moon Knight being
down we of course have the Punisher that
makes his presence known with daredevil
and the Punishers like man I've never
seen this before I've never seen the
villains this organised who the hell
made them this this organized who did
this you know how does this work but
then suddenly he's met by the arrival of
I think it's actually enchantress um who
uses her magic to basically disintegrate
him to destroy him but then we also have
the Punisher who's impaled by Kraven the
hunter this is something that I want to
point out here because this is actually
a continuity error if I remember
correctly daredevil did not die in the
original attack daredevil live and
instead he was forced to fight in the
gladiatorial games under the control of
kingpin now that may be maybe a mistake
on my part it could have been done I
screwed up it doesn't really matter
either way it's kind of cool to see
daredevil get disintegrated like this
but we also have Jean Grey you know
switching back to the modern day this
all really just comes about by Jean Grey
taking old man Logan around all these
places that he remembers and you know
when he says they all attacked at
midnight you know the stroke of midnight
is when they launch their strike when
the world was basically sleeping when no
one would expect that to happen but we
learned that the reason why this is
important is because whenever criminals
committed crimes in the Marvel Universe
all of you guys ever noticed but they
almost always happen in the daytime they
almost never happen at night not only
that you know of course midnight being
the witching hour this is a time when a
lot of people are sleeping this is a
time when you're most likely to catch
the Avengers unaware you're most likely
to catch them you know in their RNR and
so by striking at midnight you're
striking at their most vulnerable
because it means I've got a wake up they
got to get
they got to get their suits on and they
got they got to jump into action um
they're not already in action they
aren't already in the midst of
communicating they got a fire everything
up and so it's just taking them when
they're when they're least expecting it
which actually works really really well
because they took over the world but
from here we jump to Hank Pym now Hank
Pimm's death is one of the coolest damn
things ever because in the original old
man Logan story we didn't know how he
died all we knew is that there was just
a giant man skeleton and what we learned
here is that of course with wonder man
down with crossbones leading this strike
against the Avengers did almost all of
them seem to have been defeated but
instead the only two that are here that
are left of this original group is Janet
Van Dyne the wasp and Hank Pym now of
course initially Hank Pym says Janet get
out of here go to New York go meet
Captain America in them they're gonna
need you to help this is that we're kind
of in the middle of no man's land here
we're just gonna have to give off a
middle America we're gonna have to try
to take it back eventually
instead Janet Van Dyne chooses to stay
there and when she does she's actually
attacked and she's killed she's
completely disintegrated with an energy
blast not only that we also have
avalanche now this is actually a really
funny situation because avalanche was
always like a c-list level character I
mean he was a c-list level villain that
no one ever took seriously and this is
one the reasons why the plan of the Red
Skull and organizing the super villains
the way they did worked so well because
you would never take Avalanche seriously
but when you are a hundred feet tall all
it takes is for somebody to disrupt your
ability to move and suddenly you come
crashing down and that's exactly what
happened not only that we also had Mole
Man who basically had all his Molloy's
attack Hank Pym so Avalanche brought him
down and the Malloys literally ate him
alive which is a genius way to kill hate
it's so smart either story is so amazing
Jeff Lemire you're a beast but but in
any event this this is really just Jean
Grey trying to assuage the mind of old
man Logan but more so than that making
him force his own demons and in fact
what she does is she takes him to you
know where the Xavier Institute was and
his reality now of course right now the
Jaime Ranch is not there again it's in
limbo
but taking him to where it used to be in
Westchester basically forces him to kind
of deal with the idea that he's the one
that killed the x-men you know and this
is her essentially saying if it was
going to happen it would have happened
by now right but there are so many
differences you know there are so many
here's things Magneto's
bad guy magneto is a good guy Cyclops
was the equivalent of the bad guy no the
x-men mansion isn't where it used to be
you know there are a lot of huge changes
now we have new spider-man there are
things that just aren't the same you
know and so it's very unlikely there's
going to be a supervillain rise up
against all the superheroes and so she
says what you need is to know that if
something like this happens you're not
going to face it alone that you're gonna
face it with friends and this is really
important because if the you know and
Geoff Amir hasn't really touched on this
too much he hasn't really done a whole
lot of offering in terms of how
Wolverine existed in the old man Logan
universe but if it was anything like
that Mayim marvel universe it was
essentially him being a loner he was
part of the x-men but he was apart from
the x-men you know he was part of their
group but not really and so this was
really a circumstance where she says you
know if you're anything like you were
before you were a loner and you felt
like you had to deal with it on your own
not only that because of the faculty
felt he killed the x-men he considered
himself to be the scum of the earth
because he was one of the contributing
factors to the supervillains taking over
the world but she says hey look you have
friends here alright you know you've got
Steve Rogers who's the who's in your
corner which mmm-hmm interesting you've
got you got Jubilee who is still alive
now Jeff Lemire doesn't tell us if she's
still a psychic vampire or if she's
still somebody that you know can do her
little plasma things and even then I
haven't been reading close enough to the
x-men they may have been reinstating her
if you guys know about that feel free to
post it down in the comments that she's
back to her old self but you've got
Hawkeye you've got puck from from Alpha
Flight I mean you've got people that
Wolverine knew in his life these are
very important people and his life it's
not just a lot like she grabbed anybody
she got important people Huk was
important during Wolverines time as part
of Alpha Flight when he was when he was
part of Department Kane in Canada before
he joined the x-men Hawkeye is there
because of the fact that in the old man
Logan universe Hawkeye was the one that
literally took him around that he went
on a journey with basically he was
Hawkeye that kind of reintegrated him
into society you got Steve Rogers there
because we'll rainfall alongside him
during World War two and you've got
Jubilee because she was the closest
thing that Wolverine ever had as a
friend you know in the old man Logan
universe and in his own past and so by
reintegrating him in with these people
who were so significant in his life
oh man Logan basically walks away from
this saying okay is entirely possible
the supervillains will take over
everything is entirely possible the
supervillains will launch an attack and
try to take over the world but if they
do I'm not going to be fighting alone
I've got
outside of the handful of people in the
x-men I've got the Avengers you know and
I've got the x-man I've got a multitude
of superhero groups on my side but
Captain America Steve Rogers is a wild
card guys because remember he is a Hydra
agent so this is actually really cool
and that's what I love about this
because stories like this give us the
front face of Steve Rogers I think I
think really having Steve Rogers here
like change the entire element of this
because this gives us the front face
this is the face of Steve Rogers shows
to the world but this guy wearing this
red hoodie and wearing this blue shirt
with a star on the front of it a white
star on the front of it he's a Hydra
agent he's working against the
superheroes and so when you know that it
changes everything that's why I say man
like Hydra Captain America is the best
like one of the best stories running old
man Logan I think is the best
but hydric hazard America is one of the
best stories running because it changes
everything every time we see Captain
America in any comic book it's like by
the way he's a Hydra agent in the
background he's a bad guy he's not a
good guy you just think he's a good guy
and it just makes things so cool it
makes things so awesome but anyway guys
if you're new here to a complex explain
the me sure hit the subscribe button
become part of the robb core if you guys
aren't as hyped about old man Logan as I
am drop a like and leave a comment down
below and let me know what you guys
think about old man Logan in the all-new
all-different marvel universe fan
because if jeff lemire god man if God
was riding old man Logan this is what it
would look like right now
what Jeff Lemire is doing right now
anyway we're gonna bring this video to
an end and I will catch you all Leonard
peace
you